it has been nearly three decades since
Paula Abdul was reeling off number one
songs like straight up and your great
part she's not perform to any of her
hits in concert since way back then but
this weekend she finally gave her fans
what they've been waiting for and only
we were backstage it's been 26 years let
me tell you something it's different
today than it was 25 or so years ago
it's evolution it's like the way you
have to come back out there and do what
I'm going to do Paul is said at the
mixtape festival in Hershey Pennsylvania
was highly choreographed reminding us of
her classic music videos I'm just so
happy to be able to come back out and do
what I love to do while I still can do
it why not 98 degrees also performed as
part of their my2k tour Nick Lachey
recently made a return trip to live to
co-host with Kelly but wouldn't say if a
job offer was made it's always a blast
man she's created New Kids on the Block
we're also part of the bill Joey
McIntyre is launching a new scripted
comedy for pop TV called the Joey Mac
project which will be produced by Donnie
Wahlberg it's a great team and we're
excited we're gonna start shooting at
the end of the month and
it's gonna be a lot of fun and Paula
told the crowd she's actually gonna tour
with the new kids next summer so maybe
this performance was a trial run and
while we're still waiting for an
official announcement Paula was happy to
meet with fans who had waited a very
long time to see her alive I wanted to
leave my fans with a good feeling and to
remember that I really am always forever
there girl is also a judge on So You
Think You Can Dance which airs tonight
on Fox